the things you notice about children
for example is if children don't get
enough good attention they'll certainly
go after bad attention because the
fundamental human currency is a tension
and it's it's one thing to be hated but
it's another thing entirely to be
ignored and i would say generally
speaking if you put people in a corner
and you made them choose you know if
they were if they had knowledge that was
transparent to themselves said well
would you rather be ignored or hated
they'd take hate it because at least
then you exist because you exist at
least in some part in your relationship
to other people and so some of the bad
behavior is
is rewarded precisely for that reason is
that it does draw attention and that
does make you signify i'm really about
solutions that's my driving force in
life at this point and i think there are
actual solutions and i thought that clip
which of course that was jordan peterson
ben shapiro and myself that was reuben
report back in
2018 sort of at the peak of the whole
idw thing and i thought what jordan was
talking about there
was something
that you're just not going to see on
mainstream media like something having
to do with responsibility and what
really drives people and the desire for
attention and perhaps a plague that is
affecting young people right now in a
new way maybe because of social media
and the rest of it there clearly was a
mental health issue here so one of the
themes that you're going to be hearing
about
over the next couple weeks obviously is
we just need more laws we just need more
laws more strict laws we just have to
take guns away all of these things
and the simple fact is law enforcement
knew about it in almost every shooting
that we're hearing about now law
enforcement usually has met with the
person or has been alerted about the
person these systems are not perfect now
we can talk about how to tighten these
systems we can talk about how to do a
better job with law enforcement but the
simple answer seems to always be oh just
give us more laws if we just had more
laws around guns if we just had more
laws around bad people and generally bad
people do bad things whether there are
laws or not now one of the main reasons
that i'm not covering uh the the
shooter's name
is because i don't want these people to
have any more notoriety i think this is
a key thing this is something that the
mainstream media is completely missing
and years ago we should have all stopped
saying their names i actually stopped
saying their names a couple years ago on
the show and it was in large part uh
from this conversation that i had with
jordan peterson and ben shapiro this is
a further clip from the cold open that
we just showed you a few minutes ago if
you think about the people who do
highness crimes like the the school
shooters people like that who do these
things that are almost inconceivable a
huge part of the drive for that is
fantasies about notoriety and and
and
and the emergence from obscurity and
anonymity even though it's
it's notorious it's hatred
the idea is i'd rather be dead and
infamous than alive and anonymous which
by the way you i think were one of the
first websites to say we're not going to
publish these people yeah because
we're giving them exactly what they want
exactly like they've been i don't take
credit as like the first because they're
several i'm trying their names escaped
me but there are other people who have
been promoting this for a while but yeah
i was late to it we should have done it
earlier and i talked to the canadian
broadcasting corporation about that
about 10 years ago about the idea that
publicizing the names of these killers
is precisely one of the mechanisms that
ensures that it will continue to happen
peterson i just love the guy that line
i'd rather be dead and infamous than
alive and anonymous
and there's something about the whole
that is perhaps within all of us right
now and maybe social media really
exacerbated it maybe it really enlarged
that thing
that people want fame they want
attention more than anything else that
this thing that was supposed to make us
social that it it did something to make
us all feel more alone right it was
supposed to connect us that was the
thing and then we got left in this world
where we feel more worthless
we have to think about that because that
has something to do with all of this
so for that reason right there i am not
going to say the shooter's name i would
hope that some other organizations i
know the daily wire is not going to do
it i'll actually talk to my friends at
the blaze and see what their policy is
on this but they are going to keep
saying his name over and over on
mainstream media and that just sort of
adds to it because then there's another
kid out there who's dealing with some of
the same issues that this kid was
dealing with and they think oh i can be
somebody too
i can be somebody too and the internet
has then so disconnected them from
reality they would rather have
that dead and infamous than alive and
anonymous thing so
we're just not going to do it